happy fall out Dave vault dwellers and
happy tomb raider and starcraft day or
just happy november the 10th if you're
not into any of that here some gaming in
super weird news take-two interactive
have sent private investigators after
amada who was working on an alternative
for GTA online posting on reddit the
modest said that two pies arrived at his
door and identified themselves as being
sent by take to the parent company of
GTA debit rockstar games they attempted
to get him to stop developing his mod
entitled 5m before getting lawyers
involved but did threaten the
possibility of legal action a group of
mothers attached to the project were
banned from GTA 5 in august this year by
them claims to offer an advanced
multiplayer environment for people to
play on dedicated servers with user made
game modes evidently rockstar isn't on
board with that as they release a
statement saying the 5m project is an
unauthorized alternate multiplayer
service that contains code designed to
facilitate piracy our policy on such
violations of our terms of service are
clear and the individuals involved in
its creation have had their social club
accounts suspended a similar but
separate project entitled GTA
multiplayer ceased production after
takes to claim that the mod project was
a rival to hip product how come have
opted to tone down the focus on female
characters bodies in the cinematics of
Street Fighter 5 originally the wrestler
amica could clearly be seen slapping her
behind and then tag-team smashing into
her foe with her partner nagesh cope
during her critical art move and as
discovered during the game's latest beta
the camera positioning has since been
shifted to be a tad left leery Capcom
have also altered the way kami is framed
in her entrance animation to be a little
less fortuitous you can take a look at
the footage for yourselves to see the
specific differences the changes have
sparked quite a bit of debate with some
users claiming this is censorship and
others arguing this helped remedy
some of the games more questionable
design choices 544 PSP has officially
beaten GTA 5's record for concurrent
steam users although it's still got a
ways to go to beat dota 2 and Fiasco GTA
5's concurrence doing music or of
300,000 players has been well and truly
left in the dust by fallout 4 as of
writing this the number of concurrent
fallout players on Steam sits at 445,000
players but this is still a far cry from
dota 2's lifetime record of 1.25 million
concurrent players and Calva strike
global offensive record of 800,000
players let me know down in the comments
which game release you're most excited
about today you can head against what
we've got stories on a new nintendo
direct and star wars battlefront install
sizes that is everything I help you
today as always let me know what
mattered to you and I will catch you
same time tomorrow